la formation professionnelle en pleine
réécriture gouvernementale vent de la
réforme élevé le moins que l'on puisse
dire c'est que ça souffle plutôt fort
bonjour nathalie gène allô bonjour merci
de m'avoir invité
vous venez d'être réélu à la présidence
antilles guyane de la fédération de la
formation professionnelle à cette
présidence vous devez dessiné une
feuille de route de cette réforme la
première question nathalie j'ai de l'eau
pourquoi le gouvernement at il voulu
restructurer cette formation
professionnelle alors c'est très simple
en fait plein d'études ont été faites
sur comparer les pays de l' ocde la
france est bonne dernière sur le avant
dernière on va dire sur le déficit des
compétences de base pour les chiffres et
22e sur 24 pour les écrits donc déjà
c'est un constat
l'autre constat c'est qu'il ya un
paradoxe terrible entre le nombre de
chômeurs qui augmente et le nombre
d'emplois non pourvus donc avec un taux
d'illettrisme important un taux
d'électronicien important il fallait
changer le système
alors justement quand on parle de
formation professionnelle trop souvent
les politiques beisiegel bord l'immédiat
de bêtes d'abord qu'une chose c'est
cette fameuse enveloppe comprise entre
30 et 40 milliards d'euros pour les
stagiaires les apprentis et pour quels
résultats donc c'est ce que constate
envie de faire alors entre autres un le
constat que le constat que c'est
difficile de trouver un emploi et que
c'est difficile pour certaines
entreprises de trouver des salariés donc
il ya il ya vraiment quelque chose à
faire et puis le constat aussi que le
système français en matière de formation
professionnelle était relativement
complexe et que cette cette loi du 5
septembre 2018 pour la liberté de
choisir son avenir professionnel cherche
à bouger les lignes et à réformer en
profondeur
donc ça va tout ça touche tout le monde
monsieur madame tout le monde vous un
mois les organismes de formation les
entreprises les instances les organismes
collecteurs tout le monde c'est la
grande révolution à l'engagement
qu'elles sont des nouvelles orientations
voulues par ce gouvernement là en v du
on veut du plus concret aux voeux fordo
bêtise de mer relever les enjeux
économiques on veut optimiser la récolte
de la distribution des fonds alors c'est
sûr qu'on cherche à former beaucoup plus
de français
ça c'est une réalité on cherche à
répondre aux enjeux économiques actuels
on cherche à suivre l'évolution des
métiers liés au numérique donc tout ça
c'est ce que vise cette loi du 5
septembre avec des particularités 1 /
donner plus de droits aux actifs
voilà il ya plein il ya énormément de
choses qui bougent dans cette dans cette
réforme qui avait la main mise sur cette
formation professionnelle les
collectivités
alors non c'est c'est un système
relativement complexe 1 aujourd'hui
c'est l'état qui élabore les politiques
des formations et ensuite ce sont les
régions qui exécute en fonction des
besoins des besoins locaux
donc voilà ce qui est très différent
face qui change beaucoup c'est qu'au
delà de la réforme il ya le plan
d'investissement compétences qui a été
décidé par le gouvernement et par
exemple c'est une enveloppe de 70
millions rien que pour la région
martinique
donc ça c'est des fonds supplémentaires
investis pour répondre à ce que vise la
loi alors les entreprises seront au
coeur du système forcément parce
qu'elles vont cotiser et bell ont elles
sont car du système puisque en fait
aujourd'hui ce qui va être extrêmement
simplifiée c'est qu'il y aura une seule
cotisation pour toutes les entreprises
ce sera le même taux 1% et ça sera plus
comme lectez comme par le passé par des
organismes collecteurs qu'on appelait
opca parce que ça sera maintenant
collectées par l'urssaf
donc il ya un grand bouleversement pour
tout le monde qui travaillent dans les
organismes collecteurs puisque avant il
y avait 20 ans au cam qui était organisé
par branche et de interprofessionnelle
et là on est à onze au pco alors les
autres co ça va être les futurs
opérateurs de compétences mais faut
savoir que même si la loi elle en
vigueur depuis le 1er janvier 2019 ya
encore des décrets en cours vient encore
très prochainement on va voir l'igas
l'inspection générale des affaires
sociales qui va venir en martinique pour
voir justement quelles peuvent être les
ordonnances à venir pour les dom
donc la prochaine ce sera lundi prochain
parce que il y a des particularités chez
nous qu'il faut qu'il faut bomber qu'il
faut c'est de comprendre qu'il faut
réformer alors enfin il faut pas à
gommer il faut oublier comprendre et les
prendre en compte
il ya plusieurs choses qu'il faut
prendre en compte sur notre territoire
c'est que par exemple dans les futures
organisations visent les opérateurs de
compétences à promouvoir l'alternance
puisque ça ça fait partie des grands
chantiers de la formation promouvoir
l'internet et aider les entreprises de
moins de 50 salariés
nos territoires 80 % des entreprises
sont moins de 50 salariés
donc il va falloir que négocier qu'on
ait des fonds à la hauteur et de notre
économie et que ça corresponde
véritablement ensuite promouvoir
l'alternance aujourd'hui les chefs
d'entreprise sont un peu frileux sur
l'alternance
il va falloir aussi adapté à nos
territoires
qu'est ce qui va se passer au vin imposé
certain nombre de choses ou bureau vafc
discuter de négocier par exemple avec
ces entreprises pourraient accueillir
des délestages erreur d'alternance
aujourd'hui vous savez que dans le droit
du travail dans le code du travail les
entreprises ont aucune obligation c'est
une obligation nationale de toutes les
entreprises ii de former leurs salariés
et puis c'est un droit pour tous les
actifs d'être formés donc à travers le
conte fonde le cpf
le fameux cpfk remplacer le dif en 2014
donc le cpf le camp de personnel de
formation qui lui aussi réformé d'un qu'
il ya des changements le concernant
puisque avant c'était des nombres
d'heures et aujourd'hui on parle d'euros
donc voilà monsieur vuitton si vous
n'avez jamais viol ton si vous n'avez
jamais utilisé votre cpf sachez
qu'aujourd'hui vous avez 3240 euros cpf
surtout hélas j'insiste pour les
auditeurs il faut absolument saisir ses
anciennes heures de dif qui représente
quand même 1800 euros avant le avant
décembre 2019 s'ils sont elles seront
perdus ne sont pas perdus pour tout le
monde elles seront perdus pour chaque
actif qui avait ces fonds la réforme de
la formation professionnelle s'adressera
d'abord aux salariés qui roulent sous
d'acquérir de nouvelles compétences ou
dit on va penser un tout petit peu à ces
personnes qui sont au chômage
ah ben très clairement le lin
problématique de la france aujourd'hui
ce sont les chômeurs donc il y aura il
ya forcément une volonté de renforcer la
formation pour les demandeurs d'emploi
et surtout une remise à niveau et parce
que la remise à niveau aujourd'hui pour
avoir des postes il faut avoir un
minimum du bac qu'on sait qu'aujourd'hui
des gens qui ont bac + 2 bac + 15 ans
pas moins beaucoup moins de problèmes à
trouver de l'emploi
que ceux qui n'ont pas ce que j'ai
appelé tout à l'heure les compétences de
base dont kiara un énorme effort fait
pour les demandeurs d'emploi concernant
ce club personnel de formation est ce
que tout le monde a compris le
dispositif
alors ça c'est une très bonne question
faut savoir que plus on a de réforme et
plus c'est compliqué à suivre donc
aujourd'hui les entreprises les hauts
elfes les actifs
tout le monde a beaucoup de mal à suivre
avec les les abréviations dans tous les
sens et comment ça fonctionne je vais
vous l'expliquer le plus simplement
possible aujourd'hui une seconde cpf
aujourd'hui vous avez 500 euros par an
avec un mix un maximum de 5000 euros et
ceux qui ne sont pas qualifiés en 800
euros par an avec un maximum de 8000
euros ils peuvent l'utiliser pour les
bilans de compétences les vae
les certificats les formations
diplômantes même des blocs de
compétences des formations très courte
donc moi je conseille à tout le monde
d'aller sur son compte personnel de
formation de saisir ses heures pour pas
perdre
déjà avant le 31 décembre 1800 euros
dernière question et on ira très vite là
dessus des tarifs de l'eau au niveau des
organismes de formation cette réforme
fait du tort
duguay alors elle fait elle fait
toujours du temps à chaque geste à elle
fait du tort parce qu'une réforme le
temps que ça serait équilibre il ya
toujours deux années difficiles donc les
organismes de formation leur auront en
plus l'obligation d'être certifié avant
2021 donc c'est un investissement et
donc forcément on va s'accrocher on va
être des organismes de formation à jean
pour réussir cette réforme
merci nathalie je n'ai loi